welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down a soer episode
[Applause]
8 the finale is here and throughout this
video we're going to be going over the
Easter EGS hidden details and things you
might have missed in it we'll also be
discussing our thoughts on the series
and going over where we think things
will be going for the future of filon
films for one final time I'm going to
need you to hit that thumbs up button
and also make sure you subscribe as
we've got big breakdowns on Loki season
2 and geny every week without the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into a soer episode
8 war is
inevitable one Must
Destroy in order to
create now last week saw thron taking a
sort of defeat on paria after aaka
showed up to save Sabine and Ezra was a
bit of a cope though cuz man said he
actually wanted to lose cuz now they had
enough enough time to fill up his ship
the Chimera clearly he's been set on
returning to the main Universe which
does come to pass during this entry he
also seem pretty worried about Anakin
who we'll talk about more later on in
the video Balin ended up bailin on shin
and the two parted ways were they
getting an offer she could refuse I know
the episode did get a bit of hate online
but they kind of needed to set things up
for this one so we can get into what's a
big loss on the horizon for the new
Republic anyway that should be fully
caught up and we begin by looking at the
back end of the chimera I love how you
get a lot of focus on its engines and
you can see that the two main ones are
destroyed this is why they basically
need the big hyperspace ring and this
episode sort of does a reverse UNO card
and ends up with Ezra and Thon returning
to the main Universe while Sabine and
Ahsoka get left behind this showing the
back kind of hints to us seeing the back
of it but I think we might be reaching
there but I thought it was just a nice
bit of imagery to start the episode with
either way the Chimera has been a big
thing in the Legends continuity and that
had it appearing during the Battle of
Endor
however this was then reccon and it was
all reverted back when Disney took over
that had it being taken out during
Rebels which ended with us getting a
time Jump taking things post battle I've
also seen people asking what painting is
on the bottom and this itself is its a
namesake the Chimera it's appeared in a
number of art involving the character
and it's something you saw when he was
part of the chess Academy a chimera is a
monster made up of many part and the
ship sort of echoing that now due to its
repairs now Thon decides to dispatch two
Tie fighters to take out the hero and he
talks about not overestimating the Jedi
he references his loss to Ezra and talks
about how he fell victim to the actions
of a single Jedi even I fell victim to
the heroics of a single Jedi wasn't
really single if sabine's going across
the galaxy forum but we also get it
further confirmed about how Morgan
discovered Throne it was Morgan who
detected the night sisters across the
Galaxy and in return as a thank you they
give her the gift of Shadows this is
very much like a nunery in which she has
to sacrifice her life and desires and
everything she wants to become a part of
them it's sort of like how the Jedi
operat to with her having to give up all
her possessions in order to become part
of this higher power infusing her with
nightsister magic Morgan's eyes turn
black and we see as the tattoo like
markings are added to her face they then
bring forth the blade of talzin which is
a reference to damir's Mother Talen this
is probably the weapon she used before
she died but either way it's an
extremely powerful sword now the great
mother could really become a big threat
in the main universe and another night
sisters have appeared throughout the
Saga we've not seen them at this level
normally they're separate from the
Imperials and though characters like
Ventress became an Inquisitor they're
sort of off doing their own thing
they're clearly based on the witches of
MC Beth and mythological archetypes with
them helping to heralding great power
changes episode two was called tiil in
trouble which is a quote from the three
witches that appeared in MC Beth as we
know this involved a man who became an
almost Unstoppable King which could be
roughing on where they take taking
things with thwn the witches themselves
are also named after the sisters of Fate
with them sharing almost identical names
to the three from the Legends they to
aided Zeus and the guards and in both
cases they were eventually toppled
they've talked about the threads of fate
and destiny and are likely going to
follow a similar Arc to what they do in
the myths these sisters were later
adapted into the nons Which pull
directly from no mythology balen skull
and shin hadti are named after the Norse
wolves and thus they're tying all these
Legends together I think that they'll
Aid Thon in the main universe and help
him take over things for a while but as
we know yeah the sequel Trilogy is
coming I don't know if it's better to
take some of the conflict back to the
Brian side and then at least it's not
riing on wrapping up by the time somehow
Palpatine returned either way their doer
mystical Magics could change the cosmos
and they have the ability to reanimate
the dead and communicate across great
distances now after they bestow their
powers we cut to the title and get a
further reference to the chronicles of
nnia this episode is called the Jedi the
witch in The Warlord which is a not of
the title the line the witch in The
Wardrobe Bon's taken inspiration from
this before too with the world Between
Worlds being a reference to the wood
Between Worlds now at this point we cut
to the T6 and a caravan of nauy and in
case you missed our last video Tom on
the Mike pointed out they resemble a
chel from Star Wars resistance Senator
xiono or appears in that too so it looks
like they're pulling lots of elements
from that in also I know people suspect
zono is an imperial Remnant but he
actually shows up as an older man
resistance with his some being the main
character of that spin-off show makes
you wonder if somehow it's all connected
but don't worry your little head about
it mate cuz you're going to look great
how Paul how do I do that well you just
go below the video and pick up one of
our soer and Spire t-shirts we've got
ones if you want to get naughty like the
naughty and also an aaka and Gru one
quoting their very first meeting all the
te's help support the channel and get
videos like this made so if you've
enjoyed our coverage then please check
them out now speaking of decking is self
out we see Ezra creating a lightsaber
sort of reminds me of the deleted scene
from Return of the Jedi in which we
watch Luke building his green one just
before jabbers however moments like this
have happened across the Saga and we see
as huyang oversees the creation of it
Huang is thousands of years old and he's
a character that's helped to make
lightsabers for countless numbers of
Jedi this is why man's getting so
involved with it and he gets pretty
annoyed with that Ezra's just rushing
through it now Ezra's fighting style got
a lot of crap last week but I think that
was is actually a reason for it the fact
that night sisters don't use kyber
crystals shows there's not really any in
this galaxy and Ezra had to wait for
hang to bring some so that he could
create this weapon Ezra also hadn't used
a lightsaber for about 10 years unless
he he probably felt like he'd be a
little rusty I used to play the drums
mate yeah I used to play the bloody
drums and I'd hit that kick like it was
the like button now I haven't
played it for about 15 years and I went
to do it the other week and I was
so I can see why he's done
what he's done anyway Force karate and
the force being his ally is something
that Yodo actually said himself martial
arts and things like teras cassia key
fighting elements in Star Wars with them
being a major factor when Lucas was
crafting out the universe the Jedi
themselves are based on Samurai and the
lightsaber Jewels also AED Katana
fighting Jedi were also never meant to
go on the attack and only ever act in
self-defense this is the key to several
self-defense Arts with it being an
Eastern philosophy when it comes to
combat the Sith on the other hand and
they meant to strike in Anger which yeah
kind of ties it all together and I'm
glad we're kind of going back to kwaii I
might I like it but I don't know you
guys don't so yeah I was expecting him
to build one and saving it for the
finale will hopefully win around the
Nays but we'll see I'm not sure how this
episode's been received and yeah they're
all high and low points so I think there
probably will be mixed feelings on it
but either way they discuss Kanan and
hang refers to him as Caleb which was
his original name when he was part of
the Jedi Order we actually saw him
escaping during the start of bad batch
episode 1 which happened during the
events of Order 66 blang talks about the
relationship between master and
apprentice and this is something we
further see with Sabine and Ahsoka later
on the fact Sabine stays behind shows it
wasn't just about saving Ezra and th it
kind of brings things full circle from
here now this closeness to canan's
reflected in Ezra's lightsaber too with
him getting the same amid that his
master once had there were only two and
with him getting this it kind of
reminded me of Harry's War being
attached to Voldemort then the guy whose
name we don't say now let just boxs it
up and we see that it's a blue
lightsaber after having a green one at
first which now belongs to Sabine this
is kind of like the opposite to Luke who
goes from blue to green in the original
trilogy Sabine ends up going off
realizing she's kind of let everyone
down and we learn why ahoka left her in
the first place ahoka was afraid of the
fear growing and Sabine fear she's been
holding on to since the destruction of
Mandalore Mt was talking about this with
with me and he kind of related to being
like her own Master Anakin Skywalker she
was afraid of sabine's fear being a path
to the dark side for her so we can see
why Ahsoka was so hesitant in training
her outside we catch her meditating on
the roof and she says Anakin always
stood by her even when no one else did
he
always stood by me even when no one else
did this is most likely talking about
when she was in trial by the Jedi and he
was the one that believed in her Mt also
pointed out out as sua's face cringes
when Sabine says that she tries this
happens just before Sabine corrects
herself and says that she does which is
a clear indicator of what Yoda taught
Ahsoka Ahsoka then says being a Jedi is
not about wielding a lightsaber as she's
trying to teach her that it's not just
about killing people it reminds me of
when Yoda said Wars not make one great
or great ones make not War what whatever
the lesson was but it was very important
Al you might here I've got got the
sniffles this morning guys so apologies
for Hara sound crapper than usual but
we're going to keep moving now being a
Jedi is of course about training your
mind in order to conquer one's fears and
training the body in order to be able to
protect life in the world Between Worlds
ahoka argued about being a soldier and
this clearly reflects the lessons that
she learned in the domain anyway the
moment of peace is broken up by the Tie
fighters and you can actually see the
pilot helmet have a crack in them we
later get a confirmed something we've
been talking about for weeks which is
that these Troopers had elements of
necromancy in them and the fact that the
Pilot's helmet is cracked kind of
implies they've been in what's likely a
fatal crash before Pilots don't tend to
get dense in their armor because Tai
Shields are weak and Pilots rarely
survive their destruction unless your
kylo Ren and Rise of Skywalker and then
you can just walk away from one of the
worst crashes ever now later on thron
tells Enoch to Mark the captain for a
citation but obviously the guy is dead
so this would have to happen when he
comes back to life it's a great bit of
foreshadowing for the undead reveal and
yeah it kind of teases what's going on
with them also I love the bit where
Sabine rushes to the cockpit and we can
see her bump into huyang his Expressions
hilarious and yeah just a nice little
detail that adds a bit of Comedy to the
scene either way they stop them but it
messes up the ship and this yeah this
this is going to slow them down could
across to thron which is when Enoch
brings in the news and I think the way
his back's turned here could be
foreshadowing stuff down the line drawn
clearly completely trusts him which is
why he has his back turned to him which
could become a weakness in the Legends
he was killed by his bodyguard Rook who
stabbed him in the back because he
didn't watch it now Rook featured in
Rebels and he ended up dying so that
rules them out going in that direction I
I think he died anyway yeah characters
can always somehow return but I think
that's him out of it which is why
thron's now with Enoch now I doubt
Enoch's going to follow the same route
and I think he's more likely conjured
through Knight sister magic both he and
the stormtrooper outfit actually seem
like they're in line with the Roman n
Legion who dis appeared during 108 ad
now no one really knows what happened to
them and there's always been an a of
mystery like what's with the Troopers
here I've talked about before what I
think's going on with them and I believe
they're Loosely adapting those from the
night Trooper Rock in the Clone Wars in
fall in order the night sisters have
brought the dead back to life and it's a
quick way to provide thron with his own
Legion clones are out at this point and
we've seen with the Stormtroopers that
they aren't as reliable as their former
forces lots of Imperial Storm Troopers
defected and with the Clones most of
them stuck to their orders this even
happened when it came to betraying their
friends the Jedi showing how easy they
were to manipulate as a whole I think
it's a similar situation here and these
mysterious Warriors bring a much cooler
side of the Stormtroopers that we
haven't really seen before now Asoka
saine and Ezra end up riding out on the
Howers with them being akin to the Lo
wolves Ezra grew kinship with we see
Stormtroopers willing to sacrifice
themselves and stay behind on the planet
which I took that convo as rather than
being waiting on the planet than them
sacrificing their lives the hyperspace
ring starts to wrap around the star
destroyer and it does start to make
sense that it had to be this size as we
saw in the opening shot the engines are
busted up so it would need something
like this in order to return home during
this we also learned that th woke up the
great mothers after he found their
Temple and their Resurrection magic
helped him build his Starship thr then
says there'll be no negotiating with The
Apprentice of Anakin Skywalker and much
like Balin all Thon can see within aaka
is anakins cutting Reckless capacity for
Destruction the left side of thron shirt
also appears to have some type of
blemish on it almost like there was a
blaster hole there that was later sewed
up Mt was wondering if he got shot and
then was resurrected by the night
sisters later down the line which I
think would be a pretty pretty inventive
way to take things either way he reigns
down Hellfire on the howlers with Sabine
Ezra and ahoka all using their powers to
open the gate I felt like Sabine might
doubt herself in this moment but it
shows she's starting to believe she can
use the force I also love the disgust on
thon's face as well and from here we cut
to the gang battling the Troopers
Anakin's training made it so she could
defend against multiple forces which
really comes in handy when there's lots
of people like this they cut through
them but like a lot of shows in films
involving necromancy we then get a shot
of them all rising up together here we
can catch violin stabs in the score as
well which mimics the notes of Dan
macabra
this is also known as Dance of the death
music so I love that they brought it
across for this also nice touch that the
night troopers make zombie noises when
resurrected and yeah it's such a cool
little thing that really makes her scene
pop Sabine eventually also starts to
trust in her lightsaber once more and
equips it after putting her blasters
away C the thron who's worried they're
going to make it aboard the ship and
Morgan accepts that she has to stay
behind Morgan Elizabeth says for damir
in response to thron saying for the
Empire and this is revealing where her
true allegiances lie I was expecting her
to get taken out by Shin due to the
constant dirty looks but unfortunately
she doesn't and is instead killed by the
heroes now Morgan not being able to see
the promised land despite all the work
she's done is sort of what happens to
Moses in the Bible he was denied entry
to the promised land by God and Morgan's
not going to be allowed to travel out to
damir getting a rem match of the fight
we had back when esaka was first
introduced in live action we then see as
the pair to it out with Morgan's new
blade this glows green with night sister
energy and it reminded me a lot of the
ways magic is designed during Fallen
order making it to the Shrine we finally
see Throne on the eye of Sion with Scion
itself of course meaning air take us out
could also be a little reference to Star
Trek but yeah not not sure if I'm
reaching with that with Sabina azra we
can see she finally pulls the lightsaber
towards her and I love how you can see
the dislodged Shore just beneath the
helmet she grabs the saber and then
ignites it by his head which is kind of
similar to what happened with the pr
torian gods in The Last Jedi now so been
using the force something that's also
been a point of contention throughout
the series 2 but we've been building
towards a gaining self-belief she can do
it this brings the series closer to
George's original Vision as he believed
that everyone could use the force if
they trained hard enough everyone has
the force in them everyone there's two
sides of the force the dark side
which is
selfishness and the light side which is
compassion so we all struggle to keep
these two things in balance and
hopefully we're able to move it a little
bit more toward the bright side so
people like ganigan they had natural
Talent which explained why they could do
it well naturally they to use that guys
like Hann and stuff they could tap into
it subconsciously and this explained
their incredible flight abilities even
Finn like Finn had moments where he
seemed for sensitive so there has always
been this idea carried throughout the
Saga together the pair pull off a sort
of Matrix jump to the ship with Ezra
making the lead and then Sabine pushing
him it's finally her embracing her
powers and in the end it manages to take
him across now I believe this is the
same kind of force throw Ezra and M did
together when they were featured in that
second last episode of Rebel season 2 I
think it was Mt noticed that Ezra and
Kanan all CE to do it as well as Ezra
told Mo about it in that episode so then
goes to make the jump too however as SAA
arrives still fighting the Troopers and
Morgan saine ends up staying behind with
her master and this shows it wasn't just
about Ezra and that she was loyal to
hisoka as well Morgan cuts her handle in
half and the soka's left with one blade
and we get a final big action scene as
the pair work together Sabine and ahoka
finally learn how to team up and this is
just like how my my boy hyang wanted it
so so happy for him and while Morgan's
sister abandoned her aa's sister came to
her and that is the difference between
the dark side and Light Side uses it's
the idea of selfishness versus
selflessness and though Sabine
demonstrated the former earlier in the
season she's now embraced selfishness in
order to save her friend now with rone
there's also this need to win no matter
what and I feel the night sisters get
angry he keeps bombarding this sacred
Temple the T6 then arrives and the pair
Jump In It Together which is when they
race up and try and catch up with Thon
opening a channel Thon calls the sooka
Ronin furthering the influence of
Japanese Samurai culture onto the Star
Wars series The hyperdrives then studed
up and the T6 is blasted back and a
scene that's reminiscent of the one with
Hara when Morgan first made the jump
this leaves them taking a big fat L and
they return to the planet and the
Caravan of naughty we get Mor the AL
which we'll talk about more in just a
bit and then see Shin going out of the
tribe from here we C to Balin standing
on the hand of the father and just
beside him we can also catch a big
statue of the sun huge shout outs to Mt
for getting getting all this super early
and it's nice to see a few time actually
being predicted right for once feel like
unfortunately though they had to cut
down a lot of the ending here as they
may have teased stuff happening further
with Balin they don't really know what
they're doing with Ray Stevenson's death
yet and thus they kind of have to keep
it in line with is and and just tease
things for the future now elsewhere we
see thonn finally reaching damir which
the night sisters seem to be very very
pleased about Damia was very much the
promised land for them and they traveled
out from the per in Galaxy in order to
get to this planet Legion of coffins
also line the hall and elsewhere we see
is Ezra's managed to escape to Hera
finally the pair are reunited with even
little Chop Chop quelling his
bloodthirst to see his new mate now I
kind of believe that Ezra might take her
son on Jason as his apprentice and I
think that Jason will be a big character
going forward following in his Father's
Footsteps he clearly possesses the force
and is coming up in a time when Luke's
rebuilding the order I'd love to see him
become friends with the young Ben solo
and they might even do something wild
and make him a knight of Ren I always
felt like he was based on the Legends
character Jason solo who himself became
a dark Jedi and was the basis for kylo
when disy took over they of course
changed things up but I do think that
Jason will play a things a big way in
the future now the new Republic are
really starting to fall apart and you
can totally see how the first order rose
up constantly talking about these Roman
Empires similarities with the Senate
also being a big part of that too the
constant bickering and squabbling caused
several issues and they aren't really
ready to handle what's coming with thron
all the infighting and denial has left
them unprepared and th thr can come in
and really sweep the board as we know
leer ends up going off and doing our own
thing and in this fracture the first
daugh managed to rise up I think this
will end up being the Splinter that
splits a new Republic apart and leads to
it being weak enough that they're all
able to be attacked the new Republic
actually started dismantling and pulling
the fleet back after their Victory above
Endor and this left giant holes in their
remaining Amada I think that will be the
next move with thron striking out from
damir and we end with AA trying to see a
silver lining because at least Ezra got
home however they've kind of Unleashed
Pandora's Box and though they're not
accepting it th this is a pretty big L
still though Sabine has finally become a
cus Apprentice once more and Anakin
watches as he sees his Padawan becoming
a master we end with his ghost which is
sort of like Return of the Jedi and
though he smiles as sort of this hint of
sad to it too now Anakin returning that
also sort of brings things full circle
from that first tease at the end of
episode four all of his appearances have
had a thematic element to it with them
clearly being based around training the
vision in the world Between Worlds was
giving her a lesson about life in death
and even the Hologram was training her
in a certain way they've constantly
retained this master and Apprentice
relationship with her not only learning
from his Pros but also from his cons a
sooker of course knows the dark man he
became man in oppos opposite to this she
clothed herself in white he was said to
be someone who'd bring balance to the
force and we've seen lots of people who
follow on from him help to fulfill that
Ahsoka has sort of become Ahsoka the
white raz's grandson kylo Ren became a
dark sit Lord Luke did his his Luke
thing and drank blue milk but he trained
kylo carrying this on either way Anakin
now sits on a higher plane of existence
able to access the Living World by
harnessing the force there was a comic
that talked about how Quon became a
force ghost and that he said upon death
he was absorbed into the cosmos
concentrating though he was able to
regain his identity and his memories
came back after having just become an
Essence Anakin still has several people
pulling him back and he likely feels
gilled from how he lived his life his
entire lesson to a CA was about making
her remember he was once a good man and
this was so she couldn't get thrown off
in a battle Ahsoka blamed herself as she
left the Jedi Order and though she had
to be reminded so it was no longer a
weakness now I think Anakin may be
revealed to be morest God which again
the statue with Balin teases in the
Clone Wars Anakin actually clashed with
his son who as we mentioned before this
statue belongs to I think that he may
become the father with Luke becoming the
son and aaga could even end up becoming
the daughter and know he had L but he
didn't fully train and from a technical
point of view it would make more sense
to do it with Rosario since Carrie sadly
passed away I was also tying with the
idea of balam becoming the son as he
seems to be tapping into something
beyond the simple understandings that we
have the force this was by Design 2 and
filon said he deliberately made balin's
lightsaber orange so he could show he
was neither SI a Jedi even some of his
first words were we are no
Jedi so it does make sense that they
take things in a different direction
sadly as we know Ray Stevenson passed
away and yet it's still kind of up in
the air exactly what's going to happen
to his character ahoka becoming the
daughter though actually makes a lot of
sense as she was resurrected by the the
daughter's original energies the
daughter herself sort of manifested in
the AL morai who did go on to become an
ally of ahoka morai of course appears on
that rock as well and I think that filon
will carry on the daughter themes in
case you don't know the AL became a
convo of the daughter with some saying
she was a physical manifestation of her
morai actually appeared in the world
Between Worlds and this is what led to
Ezra pulling aaka out also important to
bear in mind here you can see that there
was a daughter statue however this is
crumbled away possibly leaving the
position open the father and the son
didn't die either or as the order did so
the crumbled statue being here makes
sense the medically thus I think they're
lining this up together with the moris
gods being a way to defeat Thon and all
sou Knight sisters the idea of a trinity
is of course present in a lot of
religions but it's also very present in
Star Wars and can be seen through lots
of mediums the moris gods were a trinity
and even the night cisters in their
temples they've all been aligned with
three figures as well the star map to
peridia was opened up through creating a
triquetra which itself is too link
directly with the Trinity lastly we also
have the ancient god figures on zepha
which may be repeating here as we can
see their text in the walls so I think
this series and what's to follow is
about building around a new Trinity for
The Saga now as for the feature thron is
back and he's ready to bring a Reckoning
with him going forward I think we'll see
a grand time between now and the sequel
Trilogy where we'll basically watch the
Disney version of a to the Empire it's
long been said of suck is getting a
second season but I think beyond that
we'll see the Disney Plus shows all
combining for this big event I think
just in general for Disney that they
need to start doing several seasons and
stuff cuz like yeah if you ever look at
the Nelson's charts or anything just
before another season of something
releases the last one will shoot up in
viewership and and you kind of have this
knock on effect Marvel have sort of
missed out on this outside of Loki and
yeah you'll often see that viewing
figure shoot up when a new season
arrives anyway when felon's movie was
originally announced it was said to be a
Mandalorian one but that's kind of
changed recently with it now being put
forth as a throne Trilogy however I
think elements of the Mando stuff will
still remain in place and we'll get this
man overse playing a big part you think
about it these shows actually fit
together pretty well too as the circle
was introduced during Mando season 2 B
was brought across as well Sabine worked
alongside B for a bit and she's of
course a Mandalorian as well so it all
ties together both featured Amando knew
Sabine she knew Ahsoka who featured
Amando and throwing was mentioned am
Mano season 2 and three and th yeah that
they're they're clearly tying them all
together he's going to become the Star
Wars version of Thanos and though
originally was tackled by Luke in the
gang I think unless they want to deage
everyone these characters are the
smartest way to handle it a the Empire
actually had similar themes to what we
have now with a book Trilogy taking
place during a time when the empire was
leaderless Thon came in and United them
once more and in his death he might
create the first order we also have the
dark force that's lying undiscovered and
this could open the gate for something
big down the line and the most obvious
things the night sisters find a way to
resurrect Palpatine which explains
somehow look you get you get the bit
Yeah you get it you don't have to keep
doing the joke either way Force infused
clones are something we've seen through
moth Gideon but I think tying it towards
a night system magic would make more
sense as we've talked about they can
resurrect the dead and this would
explain why palps corpse was so withered
infused with dark sister magic would
make him slightly more Sinister so that
could be something they end up doing
down the line I think that it will more
likely divert fully to the modest guards
with balon's Trilogy centering around
them too this could also open the door
for abelar who make him with them as she
was part of the ones known as the
bringer of chaos this could bring
balance in the force and allow the
darker elements to rise up and then
finally take over either way that ends
the episode you know it had its high
moments it kind of suffered from the the
Disney finale syndrome I call it anyway
which is where you know they have to
wrap things up while sorts of teasing
things for for the future some things
get left on The Cutting Room floor it
often devolves into action but overall I
feel this was delivered well now as for
my thoughts on the series I think it's
had its good and bad but overall that
was way more I like than I didn't the
show started off extremely slow for me
and I was all about checked out after
the first two episodes I felt like those
spent two hours basically taking us to
the point where we got at the end of
rebels and even the conflict you know we
knew we'd end up with them reunited so
it just seemed like they were going
through the motions purely for the sake
of it Lucas film they also have this
weird thing where they'll give
characters Happy Endings and then
manufacture tension so there's an excuse
to make a sequel Happ been in the case
with Luke and Indiana Jones and it's
just weird giving someone a send off
that you then have to go back on wasn't
something like The Dark Knight Rises
where the Dark Knight set up why the
character was like that and it seems
more like they're miling stuff cuz they
want to reuse the characters for money
now after those first two episodes
though I feel like the show just took
off and really got going which is when I
started to like it I think Stars has
kind of been stuck doing the same thing
for a long time with creators really
refusing to evolve Beyond what's come
before this actually seems like it's
trying to open new things up and create
new galaxies with new rules in Tech
beyond that though they also played into
the past elements perfectly and I know
people accus Anakin stuff of being Cameo
fan service but I thought that it
developed the characters Beyond just
being that not only did I see ahoka in a
new light but Anakin too and I think
filon really handled those characters
with the respect that they deserve sadly
though we know this is the last time
we'll see rice Stevenson as bailing and
there's a real sadness to seeing how
good he was guys had nothing but love
for his role but unfortunately he never
got to see it I think it's going to be
difficult to replace him but obviously I
also think it honors the character by
having him keep going such a shame and
yeah just adds a hint of sadness to the
series cuz he was easily the best bit of
every scene he was in the night sister
stuff also worked really well for me and
the casting of Ezra especially felt like
it was bang on they even had the two
scars on his face from his battle with
the Inquisitor and really paid attention
to detail with it I know there was a lot
of arm folding and standing around
signing early on but I think that it
went on the series just got better feel
like this was a really solid starting
point to build things up again and
hopefully from now on they can just hit
the ground running either way that's how
I feel about the show and obviously let
me know your thoughts Below in the
comments yo now people now people some
people yeah they also drop a like on the
video and if you want to support the
channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out now if you want
something else to watch you've got a
breakdown of genv on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this we're also going to be covering
Loki every week so make sure you stay
subscribed cuz you don't want to miss
those videos out the way huge thank you
for saying through this one I've been
Paul I'll see you next time you take
care peace